I started getting short of breath so
definitely does attack your respiratory
system and it heats the heart so I think
like those were that was one of the
worst symptoms because I woke up in the
middle of the night and I was
disoriented I wasn't able to breathe I
had a very high fever I also had started
to pick up a dry cough those are the
only two signs of of anything
the corona virus unlike other colds and
the flu that I had there was no headache
no sneezing no sniffles no sore throat
no body aches and even with that high
fever no chills and sweats that usually
get that hot and cold I'm I wasn't able
to get anybody's attention and I think
at that point you started sitting down
and having a conversation which are
stuff like okay uh this is it for me
this is it for me and my children I
won't ever see them again type of thing
but I thank God that he was with me
I was able to wake him up wake my
husband up to let him know there's
something wasn't right
biocontainment was weird I spent ten
days in there I was hooked up to all
kinds of monitors anyone entering my
biocontainment it was like Neil
Armstrong landing on the moon they were
had full bio containment suits on three
layers of gloves a motor in their back
to provide air duct tape all around
sealing off anything that could possibly
expose themselves I'm quite baffled with
life people are very interested at all
not just this guy that's got it positive
diagnosis but no symptoms stuck at home
but I guess people are fearful and night
I'm sad about that
I think I'm proved that even if you
catch the virus you can you can be just
fine when I first got here there wasn't
gonna test me because I didn't fit the
criteria after some cache scans and a
couple of tests they decided to go ahead
and test me and they came back in his
home and I tested positive
my family is on 14-day quarantine
I haven't seen my children haven't seen
my husband in days now but there was
nothing they could give me other than
ibuprofen and gallons and gallons of
Gatorade I kid that I've been through
every flavor of the rainbow of Gatorade
multiple amounts of times the light blue
is the bomb
stay away from the grape that's nasty
there is no treatment for coronavirus so
what they're treating is they can treat
a symptom so if I have a fever that
you're treated with Tylenol if I have a
cough take you're treated with some
cough medicine but my body has to fight
it off so I have to take the time I'm
surest I'll make sure that I'm trying to
keep down as much food as I can and let
my body do its job I've been here I
think I lost about 15 pounds so know
when I'm be looking like when I get a
bad hints I gotta get my hair done yeah
talk about my bunny it feels quite
surreal to be part of this huge thing
actually I step back and and you know
realize that the only see is on the news
it just dominates the headlines
everywhere we were out there there was a
lot of eight that came at us there were
some very elaborate death threats that
mounted and got worse
as the day's progresses people learned
that the State Department was going to
allow us back to the States
everybody's making jokes to that I don't
take it personal I think the only thing
that kind of bothered me was like to see
myself on the news to see my local news
station you know speak of this situation
but not even know wholeheartedly like
what was going on it's a lot scarier
when you see it on the TV but when you
read about it then what it actually is
but I'm not gonna sit up here and
pretend like it's a joke
definitely has taken me away from my
family
I'm giving me some breathing problems
and set me down for a while to
reevaluate myself and kind of you know
my life I know after this you know I
want to get out and do more all along we
were making lemonade out of lemons
looking at the glass half full not half
empty living for the present not
worrying about the past and also not
focusing on the future because all of
that was out of our control stress is
the biggest biggest contributor to
battling the immune system and it's not
good for the immune system so keeping
our stress level down is important so
just make sure that you guys are keeping
your kids safe
then you keeping yourself
safe as well that's the best advice that
I can give anybody just to make sure to
chop hand attention to your body your
body to let you know when something is
wrong and if he's telling you something
is wrong and then go head in and get
tested
[Music]
[Music]